je vais peut-être commencé par me
présenter en quelques mots je m'appelle
philippe père dont je suis et coup
infirmiers alors un égout infirmiers
c'est quoi un jour un une personne que
je côtoie dans une conférence médias oui
on est quoi un film est donc c'est un
infirmier discount
c'est un infirmier qui fait du je te
fait trois piqûres pour le prix de deux
jeux se passe allons je voyais ça plutôt
échos écologie enfin préservation de
l'environnement
mais qu'est ce qu'un infirmier d'un
faire sur le sujet c'est vrai que je
suis infirmier de formation et je
voulais travailler sur le lien entre
l'environnement et la santé
alors j'ai fait une formation de santé
une formation d'infirmier pendant
laquelle on m'a jamais parlé
d'environnement et j'ai fait une
formation de conseil en environnement
pendant lequel on m'a jamais parlé de
santé ça c'est un truc bien habituel sa
vie chacun son domaine on se marche
surtout pas sur les pieds et tout le
sujet que je traite depuis pratiquement
trente ans maintenant le sujet de ce
qu'on appelle le champ de la santé
environnementale
c'est justement la transversalité c'est
une autre vision là aussi en outre très
humaniste d'ailleurs de nos sociétés
alors un écho infirmiers jamais pourquoi
qu'elle quel peut être le rôle d'un éco
infirmiers dans notre société ben vous
êtes sans doute déjà poser ce genre de
questions jusque là tout va bien
attendez la suite de ce que je vous
racontais et puis un jour vous découvrez
un au hasard d'un reportage parce que
vous regardez quand même la télé à
travers un article de journal peu ce que
sais-je
vous commencez à lire des choses assez
abominable sur ce que l'on mange
réellement réellement soleil 50 minutes
de reportage sur qu'est ce qu'on mange
vraiment je pense que vous connaissez
pierre rabhi pire abidi d'ailleurs aux
hippies bon appétit on se dit bonne
chance c'est le chat kutxa coup de
fourchette on risque sa peau c'est
monstrueux et puis les risques liés aux
radiofréquences à la pollution de l'air
aux contaminants de divers et variés
dans les cosmétiques dont les produits
qu'on s'applique sur la poterne donc
vous commencez à voir des angoisses sur
le sujet et bien sûr comme vous avez pas
rendre des enfants à charge ou
questionner sur comment je peux faire
pour protéger leur santé de me protéger
moi protéger leur santé
du coup fort logiquement on peut penser
que vous alliez voir un professionnel de
santé
bonjour docteur je viens vous voir parce
que qu'est-ce qui vous amène vous avez
mal ou à l'écouté jusque là nulle part
justement j'ai ouvert parce que vous
avez mal nulle part il venait voir un
professions de santé
oui vous un professionnel de santé non
oui non mais là comme on dit professions
de la santé oms en temps mais dont vous
venez voir comme ça est en bonne santé
et n'est pas une roue qui frotte là où
un truc non parce que normalement on va
voir un professions de santé quand on
est malade
vous pensez vraiment qu'on a un système
de santé on n'a pas un système de santé
on a un système de maladie un système
qui ne fait que gérer des crises
sanitaires alors j'exagère
parce qu'il ya des soignants qui sont
vraiment étiqueté qui travaille vraiment
sur le champ de la prévention mais sont
pas souvent considérés très très
correctement par leurs collègues c'est
bien le problème aussi collet qui est
infirmière scolaire
elle a bien du mal quand on dit elle est
infirmière scolaire une infirmière
scolaire
elle a trouvé la retraite avant l'heure
un bon nom parce que la pente de se
cogner les gardes avaient pas envie de
se cogner les les week-ends de travail
n'est pas envie de se cogner le rythme
infernal dans les services du coup
qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle devient
infirmière scolaire à une courbe à
sauveboeuf faire une petite très
retraite tranquille pendant quelques
années
c'est le problème c'est que des
soignants eux mêmes cette perception
bien souvent des personnes qui dans le
champ du soin font de la prévention
on a vraiment une culture à reconstruire
autour de la prévention de ce que
j'appelle aussi de ce qu'on appelle plus
justement mon sens la promotion de la
santé
donc vous allez voir ce médecin qui vous
dire c'est quoi alors qui c'est quoi
votre problème d'écouté j'ai vu un
reportage hier soir à la télé c'est
absolument abominable
vous avez vu ce qu'on mange mais c'est
monstrueux docteur ès qu'il faut manger
bio est ce qu'il ya vraiment des
emballages de type plastic il faut
vraiment éviter des additifs
alimentaires qui sont préoccupants ah ça
vous angoisse beaucoup cette histoire a
eu huit bougez pas je vous prescris les
anxiolytiques
j'exagère donc ça problème c'est que les
médecins ne sont pas formés sur ces
thématiques
mais pas plus que ne le sont les
infirmiers les sages fans l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé
on a un vrai problème de compétence sur
le sujet et si vous avez des questions
sur qu'est-ce que vous pouvez manger
effectivement ce qu'il faut manger bio
est ce que les questions deviennent
abordés si vous avez vraiment ces
questions-là auprès de qui allez vous
trouver les réponses
c'est super et internet déjà faits
l'attestent comme ça alimentation
toxiques
je vous souhaite bien du plaisir entre
les sites du genre tout est sous
contrôle
tout va bien tout énorme et tout est
contrôlé tout est surveillé tout est
vous pouvez y aller tranquille on a
prévu des marges de sécurité certaines
vous pouvez manger tranquille et puis
les sites un peu plus affolants voudra
on a tous en crever puis encore
rapidement gérer vos angoisses mais le
problème c'est ça c'est qu'on n'arrive
pas à trouver véritablement quelque
chose qui puisse nous amener à il
faudrait des professionnels qu'ils
soient compétents sur cette thématique
qui soit non seulement compétent en
connaissant les différents toxiques de
notre environnement les différentes
sources les risques ça peut représenter
sur la santé et puis en trouvant surtout
des solutions parce que si le constat
c'est juste de dire regardez on en est
c'est monstrueux on a tous ont crevé ça
va pas nous mener très très loin puis on
va crée du stress et le stress est pas
bon non plus du coup il faut trouver des
professionnels qu'ils soient diplômés
formés sur cette thématique et soit en
mesure en plus de faire passer le
message de façon pratique et qui donne
envie qui donne envie parce que furent
un toxique pourrait vite tomber malade
c'est pas trés trés sympathique faire
attention à quelque chose son
environnement pour protéger sa santé
pour aller vers mieux vers un mieux sur
la santé pour prendre peu sont en compte
la santé de son enfant c'est beaucoup
plus motivant donc un vrai travail de
professionnel qui doit être formée sur
cette thématique
on est en train de former des échos
affirmait d'ailleurs on a constitué un
groupe d'une dizaine d'écoles infirmiers
aujourd'hui on en train de partir en
association pour essayer de construire
je dirais pas une spécialité parce que
le spécialité le problème c'est qu'on
revient à lourdes et sur quelque chose
très précis alors c'est plutôt une
compétence qui devrait être diffusée au
niveau des professionnels de santé dans
leur antre dans leur enfance
le pardon pas seulement d'ailleurs les
infirmiers infirmiers mais l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé
pour la petite histoire si tiens il
m'est arrivé un jour 1 dans une
conférence une femme qui est venue en
venant bas de l'amphi qui viennent voir
qu'il n'y ben écoutez j'ai appris des
choses aujourd'hui qui m'ont intéressé
parce que figurez vous que j'ai fait un
cancer du sein à quelques quelques temps
et le chirurgien qui m'a opéré un grand
pompe lors d'un des derniers entretiens
des deux derniers rendez-vous m'a dit
bon écoute et madame ça y est vous avez
été opéré on peut pas dire vous êtes
guéri pour l'instant intentions risque
de rechute votre cancer est
hormonodépendant c'est à dire c'est lié
fortement la concentration en certaines
hormones dans votre sens bref faites
attention aux hormones et d'ailleurs
vous savez vous entendu parler de ces
perturbateurs endocriniens fait très
attention à ces fameux perturbateurs
endocriniens et la lddhi perturbateur
endocrinien régime entendu parler je
suis fou de savoir un coin de ma tête
c'est un grand ponte
je vais pas prendre du temps lui poser
les questions qui lui paraissait
apparemment très très simple du coup bas
perturbateurs à monsieur le professeur
et je vais chez moi je tape
perturbateurs endocriniens et lient à
ces monstrueux getafe ça sur internet
on a déjà essayé perturbateurs
endocriniens et vous regardez alors là
ça commence très très mal parce que vous
découvrez que vous en avez partout l'
oms l'organisation mondiale de la santé
considère qu'il ya plus de 800
substances sur le marché aujourd'hui
qu'on a dans notre quotidien qui sont
perturbateurs endocriniens ou
soupçonnait des perturbateurs
endocriniens et là il m'a dit problème
c'est qu'un en a partout dans les
cosmétiques dans l'alimentation dans les
textiles dans l'est c'est sur mon cancer
il ya eu une grosse chute et c'était
difficile pour elle le trouve une
information qui soit un peu cohérente et
qui donne n'est vraiment quelque chose
facile les perturbateurs endocriniens
si vous n'avez entendu parler d'être une
très grande famille effectivement qui
commence à inquiéter beaucoup les
spécialistes 800 substances et des
substances qui interviennent en plus
souvent alors sur des mécanismes
hormonaux les mécanismes hormonaux c'est
d'une extraordinaire complexité on a à
peu près une cinquantaine d'hormones
dans l'organisme qui joue à des niveaux
de concentration extrêmement faible de
l'ordre de dilution pratiquement de
quelques gouttes de quelques millilitres
d'une hormone dans une piscine olympique
oui les niveaux de dilution ce est
extraordinairement élevé est néanmoins
cette super efficace pour les personnes
qui ont eu des problèmes de thyroïde
vous le savez par exemple le sous dosage
ou le surdosage des hormones
thyroïdiennes va comporter des effets
assez conséquents sur votre qualité de
vie donc les dosages très très faim
réglé très précisément et qui régule à
peu près toutes les fonctions dans
l'organisme et qui régule notamment
beaucoup pendant la toute petite enfance
et la vie intra-utérine le développement
de l'individu et là on parle d'un autre
concept qui est passionnant et un peu
flippant faut bien le dire le concept
des mille jours les 1000 jours ça
commence quand ben voila quand la petite
graine de papa rencontre la petite
graine de maman jusqu'au deuxième
anniversaire
si vous faites le compte d'ailleurs
c'est assez surprenant ça fait
pratiquement 1000 jours 1000 jours qui
constitue une période à très hauts
risques par rapport à l'exposition
perturbateurs endocriniens
parce que ces perturbateurs endocriniens
peuvent bloquer peuvent modifier
pleuvent ouais d'une façon ou d'une
autre
interférer avec des mécanismes une
extraordinaire précision et qui sont sur
des schémas de développement extrêmement
précis le développement d'un individu
qui part d'une cellule dans le ventre de
la femme jusqu'à un individu un enfant
qui va naître
c'est un travail extraordinaire d'une
complexité inouïe de développement
d'interaction de tissus et aidera sur
une horloge d'une précision d'une
mécanique absolument un peu impeccable
sauf qu effectivement ces perturbateurs
endocriniens et bien c'est un petit peu
la discorde il sème un petit peu le
doute et le problème parce qu'ils vont
s'immiscer
ils vont aller se fixer sur des
récepteurs qui était censé recevoir des
hormones certes ils vont les se fixer
sur ces récepteurs mais ces récepteurs
vont recevoir ce message comme étant un
message hormonal alors ce n'est pas une
aumône
c'est un mimétique hormonal nuku hiva
conduire ce récepteur ainsi fixé sur
l'hormone va conduire à une réponse
inadaptée de l'organisme et ça si ça se
fait d pad clé du développement
intra-utérin malheureusement ça peut
être irréversible si vous êtes exposés à
des perturbateurs endocriniens quand
vous êtes adulte
à moins que ce soit de façon répétée
dans le temps les risques pour votre
santé sont très faibles a - encore une
fois d'être répétée dans le temps parce
qu'encore une fois c'est comme les
perturbateurs endocriniens c'est un
petit peu
les hormones il agit justement à très
faible dose
du coup les toutes petites quantités
assumer a cumulé les unes après les
autres chaque jour vont constituer au
total un risque important mais celle
très jeunes enfants ou dans la vie intra
utérine
il suffira malheureusement de la
mauvaise exposition sur un jour deux
jours tout au plus par la femme enceinte
par le très jeune enfant pour que
l'effet soit irréversible on observer
comme ça d une étude qui a été publié en
2005 un 2015 pardon qui est passionnante
qui montre que les femmes qui ont été
exposées in utero à du ddt le ddt
dichlorodiphényltrichloroéthane c'est un
insecticide qui a été un développé dans
les années 40 et qui a été l'insecticide
le très massivement utilisés à cette
époque jusque dans les années 70
d'ailleurs savez on parle on évoquait
tout à l'heure les trente glorieuses et
trente glorieuses quand on parle de son
environnement c'est les 30 désastreuse
cela on a fait les pires des âneries on
a inventé les pesticides les pires ce
qu'on paye encore dans des sols qui sont
contaminés pour des siècles c'est c'est
l'époque où on a fait vraiment du grand
n'importe quoi on faisait ça au nom de
la science au nom du progrès au nom de
l'amélioration notre condition de vie il
y en avait pas tout le recul qu'on a
aujourd'hui et le ddt
il a été largement utilisés à cette
époque et on s'est rendu compte dans
cette étude publiée en 2015 que les
femmes exposées in utero à du ddt
parce qu'on avait congelé du sang de
cordon ombilical époque
eh bien ces femmes 50 ans plus tard
avait un risque de développer un cancer
du sein qui est augmenté de 3 à 4 fois
exposition in utero à des contaminations
qui était sans effet sur l'enfant à cet
âge là qu'ils se manifestent cinquante
ans plus tard avec un risque élevé de
cancer du sein peut imaginer un petit
peu les conséquences toutes les
questions que ça peut poser parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça veut dire qu'il ya des
enfants qui grandissent peut-être
aujourd'hui contaminées par des dépôts
loin de ce genre dont on ne verra des
effets que 10 15 20 30 ou 40 52 ans plus
tard pas très rassurant tout ça mais
d'ailleurs quand on regarde quels sont
les effets de ces molécules de ces
perturbateurs endocriniens sur la santé
on peut faire un catalogue très
impressionnant de pathologies je côtoie
moi beaucoup de professionnels de santé
des infirmiers infirmières des sages
femmes et aussi beaucoup de plus en plus
de médecins de médecins de pédiatres de
gynéco obstétricien qui me parlent de
leurs pratiques et qu'ils disent c'est
sillonnant ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui on
voit des choses qu'on voyait pas avant
rien quand on parle de fertilité les la
baisse de la fertilité a atteint des
proportions qui sont dramatiques
aujourd'hui on trouve normalement dans
le sperme d'un homme 50 millions de
spermatozoïdes famille de sperme quand
on pense qu il en suffit d'un seul ils
font la courte échelle il faut quand
même pas mal
50 millions par millilitre de sperme la
normale quarante ans plus tôt c'était
105 105 50 et la grande question est de
savoir quand est ce qu'on va atteindre
le cap des 15
parce qu'à 15 millions de spermatozoïdes
permis de sperme ça ou le petit leur
pour plus d'efficacité 1 donc on va
arriver à une période où on va être dans
l'infertilité total chez l'homme au
rythme actuel de déclin je travaille des
gynécos un coma qui nuisent au rythme
auquel sa décline aujourd'hui ban
devrait atteindre ces chiffres peu à peu
près de 1050 2050
on rangera la contraception dans les
livres d'histoire et une époque comme ça
on racontera et quand j'étais jeune
l'affectif mans c'est comme ça quand on
sait les bébés 1
à quelle époque tu as vécu grand père
c'est incroyable quand même 30 des
médicaments pour pas être enceinte à des
femmes ne rentre ce pauvre eh ouais ça
fait drôle vous imaginez 2050 alors
d'ailleurs c'est assez curieux parce
qu'on observe des variations de qualité
du sperme très variable selon les
régions de france
par exemple la région se déclinent
pratiquement plus vite c'est la région
bordelaise
alors que du côté vous du côté de la
franche-comté parme ça bouge très peu
mesdames si vous voulez vous reproduire
lisez plutôt un habitant du côté de
besançon dole lons-le-saunier que plutôt
de bordeaux et quand je formais des gens
du bordelais l'an dernier justement
aujourd'hui mais cette disparité
régionale vous attribue à quoi on est
aussi la première utilisation de
pesticides dans les vignobles un ancien
en france
oui il ya peut-être un lien parce qu'on
sait d'ailleurs chez le monde dans le
monde agricole
ces pesticides affecte fortement la
fertilité alors là je vous ai pris un
cas mais on pourrait en citer beaucoup
d'autres et des malformations des
pubertés précoces très impressionnante
je travaille des spécialistes qui qui
racontent leurs observations et qui en
sont eux mêmes qui ré un peu secoué des
pubertés précoces qui se plaignent des
gamines aujourd'hui à moins de 5 ans
en moins de trois ans à moins d'un an
dans des cas extrêmes qu'est ce qui se
passe dans la tête de ces gamines
pubères à cet âge là qu'est ce qui se
passe dans la maturation cérébrale
on sait que ces gamines qui font des
pubertés précoces sont bien plus de
risques de tomber ensuite dans les
problèmes de consommation de stupéfiants
de délinquance des problèmes sociaux
divers et variés c'est les grossesses
précoces
c'est aussi des problèmes d'infections
sexuellement transmissibles c'est pas
seulement un problème de puberté précoce
c'est le problème de l'évolution de nos
sociétés dans une direction qui est
extrêmement hasardeuse duquel on ne sait
pas grand chose si ce n'est que ça m'a
bousculé beaucoup de choses soyons très
prudent et là on pense que c'est
beaucoup de ces facteurs sont liés
aujourd'hui les évolutions sont
tellement rapide que pour beaucoup
d'auteurs ça peut pas être autre chose
qu environnemental
ça veut pas genetics a voulu trop vite
donc si c'est pas génétique c'est
environnementale 6 et environnemental ça
vient de quoi et bien la plupart des
spécialistes parlent aujourd'hui des
perturbateurs endocriniens et là il y en
a beaucoup des perturbateurs
endocriniens le disait et ces
perturbateurs endocriniens non seulement
ils sont en train de bousiller la santé
mais nous coûte horriblement cher en
milliers de milliers de milliers 153
milliards d'euros dépensés par an pour
compenser les effets des perturbateurs
endocriniens
ça c'est au niveau européen c'est un
calcul qui avait été fait par une équipe
de 18 chercheurs franco américain en
c'est assez vertigineuse que ça nous
coûte aussi en terme économique sur
notre système de santé qui à cause de ça
n'est plus capable de répondre à des
urgences à des situations un peu de
crise particulière ou assurer la qualité
des soins de qualité à tous
c'est un désastre aussi financier
désastre sanitaire désastre financier il
est urgent de prendre en compte la
problématique des perturbateurs
tendez craignant de former les
professionnels de santé sur ces
thématiques et d'informer la population
sur comment réduire les expositions à
ses agents en incitant bien évidemment
les industriels aussi à se débarrasser
de ses molécules
et ça c'est bien tout l'enjeu et toute
la complexité de ces enjeux vous l'avez
vu peut-être au niveau européen
la complexité d'obtenir un accord
effectivement un consensus sur comment
réduire l'exposition enfin essayer de
définir ce que sont des perturbateurs
endocriniens on a défini ce que sont les
perturbateurs endocriniens
le vrai problème aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir comment on va l'aider finir sur
un plan politique
parce que là c'est un enjeu considérable
entre supprimer quelques molécules du
marché aujourd'hui ou supprimer des
centaines de molécules c'est très
différent alors très concrètement je
vais très concret pour terminer qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire pour réduire son
exposition à ces perturbateurs
endocriniens très nombreux on disait
jacques
il ya une réflexion de base qu'il faudra
voir sur le sujet - c'est plus - de
contaminants c'est plus de santé
perturbateurs ou non d'ailleurs
perturbateurs endocriniens ou non on est
souvent dans le gadget on et textiles
gadget on a les textiles anti anti par
exemple les textiles antitaches génial
et textiles antitaches me suis tu
achètes alors j'étais content d'ailleurs
tiens les textiles anti tache verte et
condamnera une chemise anti tache mais
le problème c'est que les composés anti
tâche semble effectivement être de
puissants perturbateurs endocriniens
on met des coups est anti tâches pour le
bébé est content bébé des couettes anti
tâches et puis là en plus attention
il a le truc anti-acariens il à la
couette anti-acariens tout coup et anti
acariens qui va contenir là aussi des
composés de type pesticides comment se
comporte l'ensemble de ces composés dans
l'environnement de très jeunes enfants
on n'en sait rien on n'est pas sûr des
conséquences sanitaires directement en
tout cas ce que l'on a pu observer c'est
une contamination de nos enfants par ces
perturbateurs endocriniens et quand on
regarde les modèles animaux et ce que
nous disent les modèles animaux exposés
à ces faibles doses alors on prend peur
et les textiles faut faire dans le
simple l'alimentation four venir du
simple on essaye toujours de nous
trouver du toujours nouveau dans
l'alimentation
mais on n'a pas changé le tube digestif
du coup il faut faire quoi c'est très
bien mais ces dix essais répétés manger
des fruits
manger des légumes manger des fibres
manche et des légumineuses consommer
moins de sucre
les règles de base c'est bien parce que
les règles de base nous assure quoi la
santé et la longévité a priori sur
effectivement la réduction en tout cas
de ces risques sur la plupart
effectivement de ces maladies chroniques
que ce soit lié à beth l'obésité le
cancer tata est aussi ça nous aurait dû
très sensiblement l'exposition aux
perturbateurs endocriniens et d'ailleurs
pour la petite histoire l'agriculture
biologique
n'utilisant pas de pesticides on va être
quelque chose de très intéressant pour
réduire l'exposition aux perturbateurs
endocriniens manger les produits bio oui
je vous le recommande
pendant la grossesse une femme qui
mangent des produits bio à moins de
risques de développer chez son enfant
des malformations au niveau de
l'appareil génital parce que j'en ai pas
trop évoquer mais les petits garçons qui
naissent aujourd'hui avec des
malformations de l'appareil génital
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux des
micro pénis se dit bien ce que ça veut
dire ça peut faire sourire mais ça fait
pas rire du tout des personnes touchées
personne ni les parents qui voient ça
chez l'enfant des problèmes de
testicules qui ne sont pas descendus des
problèmes de de pénis malformés aussi à
fin mars
on a toute une série de malformations et
on sait aujourd'hui les études d'une
très grosse étude a été publiée l'an
dernier qui montrait que les femmes
encore une fois enceinte avait beaucoup
moins de risques de développer chez
leurs enfants ce genre de pathologie
si elles mangeaient du bio pendant la
grossesse ça ne fait que corroborer les
modèles qu'on avait dans les populations
animales c'est relativement logique
et puis les pesticides faut éviter aussi
dans l'habitat parce que dans l'habitat
on en met les pesticides sous forme de
spray sous forme de trucs qui se branche
sur les prix et sur et les produits
qu'on applique sur les sur les animaux
c'est d'animaux de compagnie je vais pas
vous citer des marques voyez des petites
gouttes comme et au niveau du peuple a
appuyé sa diffusion toute la bête ça
c'est des produits qui ont été interdits
en agriculture il ya pratiquement une
dizaine d'années des puissants
perturbateurs endocriniens le fipronil
c'est incroyable ce soit encore dans ce
genre d' usage et d'ailleurs on trouve
chez les enfants qui ont dans leurs
foyers des chats ou des chiens pretec de
fipronil on trouve ce genre de choses
dans leurs cheveux
c'est 60 millions de consommateurs qui
le montrait dans un numéro ya ya un mois
de soldes
donc on arrête ce genre de choses et
puis on s'en fou surtout pas sur les
doigts je dis ça parce que j'ai vu
carrément un vétérinaire médias l'autre
jour à mais c'est vachement efficace
chez les enfants quand ils ont des
points
je le regardais comme ça j'ai un
vétérinaire
mais c'est vachement efficace contre les
poux non mais attendez c'est pas fait
pour c'est parfait pour les humains
c'est parfait pour les enfants un oui
oui non japon c'est vrai que j'ai pas il
faut pas vous en [ __ ] sur les doigts
quand vous traitez votre animal faut
même pas caresser votre animal dans les
heures qui suivent le traitement faut
juste respecter le mode d'emploi
et puis mis encore trouvé des substances
alternatives vous en trouver dans
n'importe quelle jardinerie maintenant
des produits qui ne contiennent pas ces
molécules
ça c'est un exemple autour de pesticides
parce que c'est quand même la classe de
produits la plus préoccupante
je vous signale aussi en vrac des côtes
des labels qui sont intéressants le
confiance textile sur les textiles parce
qu'on trouve des composés douteux dans
les textiles sur les produits ménagers
on trouve dans les produits ménagers des
perturbateurs endocriniens offerte c'est
dangereux de faire le ménage
faites gaffe et on peut revenir à des
choses beaucoup plus simples encore
toujours le moins c'est plus on peut
revenir au classique sabre noir au
vinaigre blanc enseigne les grands
classiques dans les cosmétiques
attention dans les cosmétiques beaucoup
de cosmétiques contiennent des
perturbateurs endocriniens
il ya des pays d'europe du nord ont dit
à des femmes enceintes madame vous êtes
enceinte vous ne vous parfumer pas votre
enfant vous ne le parfumer pas parce que
dans beaucoup de parfums on trouve
aujourd'hui des perturbateurs
endocriniens
c'est quand même préoccupant de voir
aujourd'hui des parfums des gammes de
cosmétiques pour les bébés il ya déjà un
team pour des signes est de moins de
cinq ans au sahara était un petit peu
l'hygiène la plus simple c'est aussi
l'avis jeunes avec un simple savon
correctement conserver on arrête aussi
on fait très attention j'étais au parfum
attention aux vernis à ongles attention
à ce genre de choses notamment chez les
filles est pré pubères
ça c'est quelque chose qui est documenté
aussi une gamine qui est pré pubères qui
n'êtes pas encore pu berne ne devrait
pas manipuler des cosmétiques et sont
plutôt destinées à sa mère on laisse le
temps à ces gamines de devenir une femme
en attendant eh bien on réduit
l'exposition à ces contaminants dans les
cosmétiques en choisissant parents des
cosmétiques avec des labels comme ce que
vous avez et puis vous avez en bas à
gauche là bas notamment un label
notamment sur les jouets parce que même
dans les jouets on peut trouver des
composés douteux mais là encore revenir
au simple nettoyer les textiles aussi je
disais avant de les porter par exemple
elle avait une ou deux fois même avant
de les porter directement contre le
corps pour les enfants il avait deux ou
trois fois et privilégier textile
d'occasion
c'est ce qu'on va faire face entre le
numéro 2 1 le numéro un à la rigueur on
lui achète que du neuf
le numéro deux va récupérer a fait son
grand flou de sa grande soeur c'est
vachement dangereux d'être les né dans
une famille aujourd'hui il ya plein de
solutions suffit juste d'aller chercher
un petit peu ce genre de d'aller les
chercher on trouve beaucoup sites
internet notamment qui vous apporte des
solutions sur l'exposition à ces
perturbateurs endocriniens
mais c'est un vrai problème de santé
publique qu'il faut prendre aujourd'hui
à bras le corps ce n'est pas seulement
un problème de santé c'est un problème
d'avenir tout simplement de nos sociétés
en plus d'être d'ailleurs un problème
d'ordre économique je vous remercie de
votre attention
[Applaudissements]